[Applause]
[Applause]
you've got debate fever that's what it
is did you watch all four hours so how
many watched all four walks out nobody
okay I think I know what America's
biggest problem is now overcrowding
there was 20 liberals
on stage Fox Fox News called at comicon
but the debates of course were held in
Miami so for an old Jew like Bernie
Sanders it was a home game and oh it
started out strong burnt Bernie promised
health care for everybody and after what
Kamala Harris did to Joe Biden Joe
needed it Joe definitely got his bell
rung a little bit didn't he I mean by
the second hour he was sniffing his own
hair that was luckily Mary Ann Williams
brought her
what're healing crystals is always the
last show before a vacation I'd start to
lose it so help me luck but I thought it
was really interesting that this was I
thought Joe is actually worth moment
they went around and they asked it what
would be your first act as president and
Biden said to defeat Donald Trump yeah
that's when the kids came on stage and
took away his driver's life
first of all I want to say I always come
out against ageism but before I say yo
your hypocritically do old jokes yes I
do bloody old joke because ageism does
not mean everything old people does is
okay it means judge people individually
by who they are and how they acted I'm
sorry it's a case-by-case basis
some people do look good at Joe's aid he
didn't look good last night he did look
kind of old and it works the other way
swell well looked too young kept asking
to pass the torch past the torii you
wouldn't stop bringing it up finally
yang offered him a thousand dollars to
shut the [ __ ] up
but I mean honestly the Democrats so off
in their own worst enemy still you know
trying to get the Twitter mob and said
it'd be 98% to give a [ __ ] about Twitter
on the first day who Leon Castro won the
woke Olympics on the first night when he
said trends females should have the
right to an abortion I agree
now if only they had a uterus
[Applause]
[Music]
strike selling that in the red states if
a man identifies a woman then we stand
with her right not only to imagine that
she's pregnant but to terminate that
pregnancy which is not possible really
oh they were going nuts that first night
they were trying to out Spanish each
other and then deceive de Blasio I am
the only person on this stage with a
black son it was like Billy Zane and
Titanic I have a black son he announced
his new campaign slogan different
strokes and then and then they were
asked to give the closing statement you
know what's the most important thing to
you they all said their thing and Mary
Ann Williams had said to beat Trump with
love and Putin tweeted in he said make
sure to get it on tape
you